[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi Bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata Show oggi avremo
Frank Matano tra parentesi le reduce
reduce da LOL possiamo dire Claudio Di
Biagio
Claudio
c'è una cosa che pochissime persone
sanno che tu hai collaborato in un certo
senso con LOL così ho diretto
generazione lol e poi abbiamo Matteo
Bruno che non fa ridere e quindi diciamo
non c'entra un cazzo
allora ragazzi Io ho chiesto Scusami
e ho toccato un occhio Quindi durante il
video vedrete l'occhio sinistro
a tutti i cani praticamente vedete
l'occhio sinistro di Claudio che piano
piano diventerà sempre in grado lo dico
perché magari si preoccuperanno e lo
diranno noi eh piano piano già sto
sentendo
noi chiediamo alle persone di
condividere
Che ti senti l'occhio che cresce ok
Allora ragazzi io ehm per questa puntata
di vita buttata visto che siamo in
periodo natalizio ho chiesto alle
persone e in questo Matteo tu lo sai eh
quanto noi è caro come tema di mandarci
foto dei loro regali orrendi di merda
che hanno ricevuto ricevuto per cui
mentre commenteremo le foto di queste
persone certo allo stesso tempo avremo
modo di farvi delle domande legate alla
storia di vita buttata quindi ciò che è
stato Scomodo per tutte quelle persone
che ci hanno messo gli audio Adesso sarà
Scomodo per voi che ci metterete anche
la faccia
e c'è quella ampolla quindi scegliete
voi A caso perfetto certo
[Musica]
partiamo a questo punto con la puntata
di vita buttata
[Musica]
salute prima a tutti grazie grazie
Saluta le persone che seguiranno questo
video saluto a guldo e a tutti i dottori
mi consiglieranno di non toccare più
cani
ma questo è un disegno
non possiamo vedere in faccia alla
persona che sta facendo la foto qua qua
c'è una persona veramente
la mano col telefono
Il vestito è blu per forza
ve la faccio compagnia al volo nei peli
di Freddie Mercury si nasconde Frank
No vabbè vabbè lo vedi Oh mamma Hai
visto questo viene dopo Pompei e ed era
una era una persona molto piccola di
Pompei è un'anatema secondo me è un
reperto storico questa in realtà era una
piccola persona di buon compleanno
bellissima
Hahaha
i primi che lo capiscono solo
comunque che sentono il caldo posso dire
che dall'ultima volta che sono stato a
vita buttata c'è un netto miglioramento
nel nel bevereccio perché non era così
immagino sia sempre meglio
Frank è arrivato il tuo momento di
tirare fuori un bigliettino ma prima di
farlo Ok Posso farlo
facciamo un pochino di promozione
promozione
[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi permetti postato come
rifare l'esame di Stato No tu Quando fai
l'esame di stato finisce diciamo fatto
di partecipare per me mi ha dato di
nuovo attenzione perché sembra ormai
l'hanno vista un sacco di persone sembra
vai là e non ridi diciamo comportarti
normalmente in un contesto dove mentre
parli non sorridi come faccio Adesso per
esempio ti fa strano capito ti ti dà
attenzione ci sta tipo Mara Maionchi
dentro che fa troppo ridere e poi io ho
beccato ho avuto la fortuna di beccava
Forest e no forse Lillo Di nuovo Forest
insieme Goku e Vegeta capito
[Musica]
loro veramente hanno il cuore puro
secondo me avrebbe voluto prendere Quel
bigliettino passano a prenderlo
tranquillamente tocca a te però
purtroppo
tradimenti
stavo tradendo
stavo con un mio amico Ci stavamo
scrivendo in piscina e stavamo
compilando il modulo e lui per farmi
ridere Ho scritto che poi lo leggeva La
ragazza ha scritto che nel lavoro facevi
il pescatore o io mi so mi sono iniziata
a piangere di prima dicevo
lei vedeva che lui non sembrava che mi
faceva ridere vi ricordate i video
ovviamente di scorregge sulla gente Ma
certo certo
ovviamente fare quella cosa chiaramente
se tu fai quella gag delle scorregge
sulla gente lo devi fa per forza in
ascensore Io non ci sono mai riuscito
se entrava qualcuno non ce l'hai non
partiva mai C'è stato un periodo in cui
avevo deciso di non tossire mai più
veramente sì e quindi politica proprio
mi sono rotto il cazzo e quindi invece
di tossire facevo Ah ah ah Veramente
Solo che poi è diventata la normalità
perché è un ascensore un giorno fa
domani così e poi mi sono reso conto
e quindi da lì ho smesso andiamo avanti
con i regali
ragazzi
che cosa fa lo dobbiamo dire insieme a
vedere se facciamo match con qualcuno Ok
2 Com'è bello tematici
per fare i cubetti di ghiaccio sarà tipo
tematico di ossa di Game of Thrones che
poi fa i cubetti di ghiaccio
Poverine portapacioli Ah okay Okay nel
culo hahaha
io ho detto porta fagioli Perché i
fagioli sostituiscono le proteine della
carne va
[Risate]
è un porta tovaglioli e lei c'ha messo
la spugnetta per la cucina rincoglionito
Gli a Chiunque abbia fatto questa roba
scusami
io dico così perché voglio sentire
quello che lo fai vi dovete lavarmi
quello che
non c'è nessuno perché tirava
bravo bravo bravo
e poi tipo questa signora che se ne
prende con una signora fa così con la
mano che gli fa che allora gli sembra il
vulcano capito
Claudio ma posso avere il momento in cui
questi omini si rendono conto che c'è
un'eruzione Cioè cosa stavano facendo
prima ma le cose più disparate
fischiettavano
persone ormai e poi tipo hanno visto
hanno cominciato a sentire qualcosa
pericolo
Anzi questa roba è illegale non si può
anche dire no no no no No
comunque quanti anni servono per ride
così tanto di una donna
cioè questa è una cosa molto vera cioè
c'è qualcuno che sente Forse ancora non
abbiamo superato quindi Allora secondo
me effettivamente se uno ha un po' di
buon senso fa ridere perché
un vulcano erutta è talmente che ti fa
paura che per esorcizzarle ride tipo
incredibile impossibile è una paura
tavica è esagerata quindi ti viene da
ridere che quelli piccoli quelli piccoli
poi io vorrei che vivessero quelli
piccoli non vorremmo molto alla vita dei
piccoli di Pompei solo perché sono bella
oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh Buon Natale Buon Natale prima
di iniziare questa chiacchiera con
Claudio al volo mandiamo un video
Oh ma posso dire delle cose puoi dirci
delle cose su YouTube il Mondo di Alexa
e ha trovato il canale con l'avventura
che stiamo vivendo ancora con Guglielmo
Camilla Adriano degli una parte della
Dream Dogs e con Martina che la mia
ragazza si vive un'avventura epica fuori
di testa in un mondo Fantasy originale
creato da me ma strutturato da anche da
loro da tutte le storie che avvengono lì
sul canale YouTube appunto il mondo
dell'Etna e sul profilo Instagram il
mondo di Alexa e ha trovato tutte le
informazioni tra cinque secondi potete
saltare
la vettura fuori di testa la potete
recuperare proprio in questi giorni
prima di Natale Insomma
è arrivato il momento però di usare
quella mano per the wild card
l'acquisto più inutile che hai fatto la
PlayStation 5 perché Perché non riesco a
giocare non ho il tempo di giocare Ah
veramente il tempo di giocare alla
PlayStation 5 io per un anno e la guardi
però la ce l'ho lì Matteo adesso stai
portando avanti i documentari e so che a
breve uscirà un documentario su
Guglielmo Scilla No veramente no no no
no su Danny Lazzarin posso dirlo avete
la possibilità di andare a vedere e
recuperare quelli che già fatto gli
Yotobi Tu hai già fatto Se non sbaglio
c'abbiamo io Dobby ci abbiamo Power ci
abbiamo Sio e adesso ci abbiamo Danny
Lazzarin
[Applauso]
qual è la cosa che meno ti aspettavi da
Dandy a zarin C'è sempre un momento del
documentario in cui loro devono
costruirsi con delle costruzioni LEGO e
lui ha fatto una roba notevole Quando
esce sto documentato
colleghi di lavoro c'è chi si è cagato
addosso Mentre montava magari
una persona che ha lavorato con noi così
è tutto tranquillo che a un certo punto
si è cagato addosso c'era la telecamera
di sorveglianza e quindi noi abbiamo
visto lui che si alzava No no Sì ma no
questa cosa andava in bagno e poi
l'abbiamo trovata a lavarsi le mutande
nel lavandino
è osservato tutto il suo percorso
tra l'altro introduce un argomento
adesso iniziamo questa nuova puntata ehm
cacca nei luoghi pubblici c'è una storia
io non posso fare nomi non posso fare
secondo luogo ma dirò ma tipo perché
cambi il futuro se lo dici
immaginate un ambiente tipo una palestra
Spa una signora l'ha fatta
No l'ha fatta
nell'idromassaggio
qual è il problema le persone che
lavorano lì teoricamente non potrebbero
vedere i filmati Ah e quindi loro
l'hanno vista e quindi devo dire questa
persona di andarsene senza dedicare che
aveva fatto perché sennò avrebbero
ammesso di avere o no Perché mai Dovrei
andare via Non ho capito eh
[Applauso]
io non trovo veramente il motivo
di andarmi via e con non capisco guardi
vediamo un Cadore e arrivederci finiamo
finiamo questo è un video
questo Comunque per me non è altro che
benzina per i complottisti che dicono
che ci stanno i poteri forti Satana
Avete presente quando durante la
giornata vi viene in mente un ricordo da
piccolo senza senso che sembra motivato
no E c'è questo canzoncina che fa questo
pupazzo un cane Io mo ve la faccio e voi
mi dite se ve la ricordate
I love you Comunque tra gli uomini
piccoli di Pompei c'è una truffa che
stanno a fa' hanno preso uno di quei
cani che hanno messo dei gettoni piccoli
e gli altri piccoli si fanno in giro
sopra
gioco Complimenti dove loro hanno
un'intesa su questo argomento
facciamolo fra un sacco di tagli abbiamo
giocato con i nostri utenti abbiamo
chiacchierato con voi Che bello Abbiamo
Insomma fatto una cosa meravigliosa a
Natale però è quel momento dell'anno
dove i regali Chi è che li riceve
soltanto che è stato buono bravissimo
per cui vogliamo invece tirar fuori il
vostro lato peggiore e Giocheremo a bad
People di yascames Ok così ognuno di noi
avrà due racchette double face Ok
bellissimo verranno Fatti delle domande
scomode a tutti quanti noi dovremmo
capire e a quel punto rispondere tutti
quanti insieme Cioè chi Secondo noi tra
queste persone la bad People risposta
seconda domanda
si può anche votare se stessi chiaro
chiaro chiaro
chiaro chiaro chiaro chi avete giudicato
peggio la prima volta che lo avete
conosciuto per il loro piatto per me va
bene ciao giudicato me peggio di te
stesso la prima volta
è un carattere spigoloso sei difficile
ragazzi
non sono per niente spigoloso non riesco
divertentissimo Ma ci vuole un po' di
tempo
ah ah se fossimo escort chi si farebbe
pagare di più 3 2 1 Sì
3 2 1 via
Ragazzi Ragazzi
se fossi costretto con chi Faresti sesso
tra i presenti Shh Shh vabbè vabbè vabbè
sono molto felice Guglielmo perché
questa esperienza
in questi spigoli eh Claudio perché
secondo me
lo Dillo dillo Guarda Guardami Matteo è
ingestibile Ah beh sì certo perché eh
Faccio una dimensione ti posso aiutare
Vai Metti una mano così questa è Matteo
questo è Matteo Cristiano in larghezza e
Matteo lunghezza non potremo farcela
Matteo io ti ringrazio io ti ringrazio
ma io guarda prego
qualcuno di questo quando si era la
stessa stanza con Matteo ho sentito un
peso
se fossi lo spietato dittatore di un
paese chi Sceglieresti come tuo braccio
destro ce l'ho Guarda guarda
io sento che nel mio c'è un giudizio
divertente ma negativo di te ma a me no
Hai capito se ci vestissimo tutti come
persone del sesso opposto chi sarebbe il
più credibile Però io sono abbastanza
sereno No beh Scusate ho bisogno di un
altro Oh per me Mmm non lo so Scusate
per maggioranza è vero una gamba capito
slanciata Cioè Kate Moss Kate
questo sesso nel luogo più assurdo eh
3 2 1 via
davanti ragazzi davanti al pianerottolo
di un hotel con l'ascensore e poter
aprirsi Io ogni tanto di fronte
all'ascensore è stato Tik Tok però ha
fatto così
ci stanno le persone dentro la verità
Scusami Guglielmo tolgo un attimo faccio
così mentre si aprono perché non deve e
a volte mi è servito Giusto
hai ragione Lo so Forse sono io tu
su delle scale di un building pubblico
tipo un ospedale No adesso stai
veramente esagerando quella è pubblico
anche i musei Chi ha deluso di più i
propri genitori Beh
considerando che
è questo qualcosa
io voto tutti No mi dispiace Questo non
penso nessuno siete tutti così bravi
me stesso perché mia madre
Ancora oggi ancora oggi
io sono gay Ah è vero aspetta aspetta
aspetta
durante un apocalisse zombie chissà
criticheresti per primo pur di salvarti
via io Io
finalmente
realistica io non ucciderei mai mai
Matteo Bruno perché Matteo Bruno diventa
il MacGyver della situazione dell'Inter
Io butto a te Sì perché sei inutile ok
Non è detto certo
Giulia Giuliano
eh È solo un graffio
mentre invece raga immaginatevi 12 mesi
con Claudio No ragazzi quelli mini del
Vesuvio
Lui sta male perché non può più fare la
cosa lì davanti
lo sanno
tutti
Se fossimo tutti i comici chi farebbe
ridere di meno siete tutti super
simpatici ci deve essere delle persone
molto simpatiche io non voglio
rispondere possiamo fare un momento
ipocrisia siete tutti veramente
simpatico
io io farei veramente poco ridere
Ragazzi io sono quello che farebbe meno
ridere tutti
no uno dei primi video Ah ah ah io sono
che non farei ridere Poi è difficile
formula la frase Avete presente come
sono fatti i vecchi telefoni
tipo quelli che tipo c'è un altoparlante
limitazione di una nonnina che va a
rispondere a un vecchio telefono Vai
Fallo squillare 3
Pronto Sì sì venite venite
Ti piace questa è una delle cose che per
esclusione Io sono arrivata a questa
questa è la migliore cosa sono i cinque
Questo è quello mio parere adesso
abbiamo capito il percorso creativo ha
vinto lo sport come sempre Allora Wild
Car Claudio Matteo e Frank prendete un
bigliettino
le mie manie e ossessioni
facciamo questo il volume dell'autoradio
deve essere pari Io non credo di avere
in maniera ossessione cioè
Ragazzi io non ho manie non ho
ossessione non ho cose che Ah no ce l'ho
messo un attimo Io non riesco a leggere
nulla dalla libreria alla libreria di
tipo di 5 metri Se tutta la libreria non
è enorme
Sei passato da io non ho eh ah ah da
essere internato quando avevo 20 anni
più o meno quando passeggiavo su un
marciapiede vedevo una macchina che
arrivava e se non c'hai niente da fa poi
fa un gioco nella tua testa tipo io
Secondo me qualcuno l'ha fatto pure voi
devo arriva' quel palo rispetto prima
della macchina Se non ce la faccio
e se non ci riesco perché a volte non è
che corro se non ci riesco perché a
volte calcolano sempre a mio vantaggio
che ce la farò camminando Ovviamente la
macchina sta proprio dietro
e faccio così tipo solo per me
attenzione
tipo che non ti sto camminando
rapidamente su questo schema io devo
arrivare alle Scale del pianerottolo
prima che si sia chiuso il portone siamo
arrivati alla fine Ok
C'è una sorpresa però prima voglio dire
due parole al volo noi continuiamo ad
evolverci Spero che questa diciamo
questa versione di vita buttata Show vi
sia piaciuta Mi raccomando continuate a
seguirci su Instagram in modo da poterci
dare una mano per riuscire a poi
riempire queste chiacchiere che facciamo
sia con i nostri meravigliosi ospiti ma
anche in quelle che vogliono essere
delle chiacchiere di interazioni di
gioco con tutti quanti voi prima di
salutarvi Però io ho dei regali Grazie
raga è natale ci stanno quelli là no È
Natale
un pensierino a tutti Non ci posso
credere manco mi madre quest'anno ha
fatto regalo
fantastico veramente bellissimo
sta roba calzini con il cagnolo morbidi
il giorno non sai quando ci metti i
piedi dentro come saranno per Claudio
Secondo me sono tutti bei regali che
bello secondo me questo è più bello del
tuo se ho calzini duri
un regalo per
non c'è niente non c'è nulla
io ti chiederei di attivarlo
Ma tu come fai a sapere a tutti quanti
Guarda
Guardami io sono molto
a te Non farlo troppo Non farlo troppo
che cambia
è ipnotico ed è così ed è con questa
musichetta Buon Natale Buon Natale a
tutti grazie Google e grazie che trovi
sempre il tempo di capirci e di sapere
ma comunque sembra che tu ci spinge così
almeno così
è vero È incredibile
Quindi grazie ancora a Frank Claudio
Matteo questa parentesi c'è stata anche
la storia di YouTube E invece abbiamo
iniziato praticamente siamo arrivati
è partito il gigante ragazzi buon natale
ci vediamo la prossima puntata saluti
capito Ciao
[Musica]
prendi un
mandarino Ma si scioglie nell'acqua
[Applauso]
non ne escono per due anni per questa
storia Allora si chiameranno questa sera
Ciao
[Musica]
come va Allora noi siamo arrivati qui
nel futuro e qui nel futuro fanno il
Natale non ci sono più vulcaniche Meno
male che noi siamo vivi no no no no
[Musica]